hallo mein name ist luca meiner lieben
freunde ich befinde mich hier in meinem
aufnahmen immer mal wieder nicht allein
sondern mit
[Musik]
hass so lange braucht vor einigen tagen
habe ich bereits ein video auf einem
kanal hochgeladen woche anime youtube
video ausschnitte gezeigt hat und ich
musste erraten auf welchem jahr diese
videos sind heute hat haben wir
allerdings screenshots vorbereitet wie
beispielsweise diesen hier
und ich muss sagen wie viele aufrufe
diese videos voll haben können deswegen
hami froning miss universe 2014 das wird
ja ich genau
deswegen weiß ich auch ganz viele
aufrufe das hat nämlich ich schaue mir
das ja jeden tag an
für mich sind das sechs millionen
fast sind knapp 600.000 aufrufe da habe
ich dachte ich ich
ja
gut machen wir direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten spiele ich auf meine lieben
freunde fifteen strict rules kylie
jenner hsv stormy weather warum heißt
die eigentlich webs damit schon sonst ja
genau die sache ist halt dass diese
komplette kardashian familie ja so einen
hype um sich zieht also ich würde
eigentlich von mir aus sagen dass das
video so 100000 euro pro watt weil es
keinen juckte eigentlich was juckt das
was ist ihr kind darf und was nicht
allerdings gibt es gab eine menge
anderer leute deswegen würde ich sagen
drei millionen
es sind vier millionen also kann man
schon durchgehen lassen okay mein erster
punkt er der beste der welt das nächste
der beste was der beste der welt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
trotz als nächstes video der beste team
der welt das große trostlose teekanne
twitch diente hier
[Musik]
das trostlose teekanne twitterte und ja
da würde ich wirklich sagen hat
15.000 auf
lose yourself adventskranz
ja dinge die man danach sucht wird wie
windig selber ein adventskranz
ja weihnachtsdeko natürlich aktuell sehr
gefragt in der weihnachtszeit ich kann
mir allerdings vorstellen dass du mich
ein bisschen rein legen will ich denke
jetzt wahrscheinlich erstmal borg mal
vormonat hochgeladen wirklich viel
aufrufe haben aber vielleicht ist das
der richtig durch die decke gegangen
jeder einmal mutter denkt sich das ist
es das ist mein tutorial ich sage das
hat eine million aufrufe
200.000
und dem kann also mache ich das de
ich sah keine millionen
knapp 300.000
[Musik]
12 aufrufen
300.000 leute wirklich mal nudeln crazy
frog xlf habe ich mir vor
zwei minuten noch angehört weil es mein
absolutes lieblingsgericht ist wurde vor
zwölf jahren hochgeladen
oha für alt
das haben wir haben uns damals mal mit
bluetooth herumgeschickt das wusste ich
noch nie hat das denn auf ernste zu
hause und denkt sich stelliges lied ich
will sagen das hat diese 100 millionen
aufrufe in den medien in eine milliarde
es sind 3,1 mehr drei
katzenbabys best fanny moments kids
falling down fällt dieses gerät kann es
wurde erst vor zwei jahren hochgeladen
aber dass ein so videos die witzig du
willst die so etwas angucken nadine doch
reden so hoch sei wie du willst sogar
meinen stuhl sehen ihre nicht auf
toilette
luca
bis zu packen
sein stuhl
sagen das hat ganz lockere zwei
millionen
56.000
ich möchte diesen einen ford transit für
werden live ausbauen
ich glaube dass 100.000 3,2 millionen
da muss ich zugeben
sowie alter die gucken stuhl wie kann
ich krawatten bin für anfänger danke
dass du mir weiterhilft ich glaube ich
musste ich glaube ich hab noch nicht mal
im leben eine krawatte gebunden weil
auch so auf die entlassfeier oder
bachelor fire oder so ich hatte immer
noch ne fliege
[Gelächter]
schon komisch das haustier irgendwie ja
ich sag zwei millionen 5 mio
halber punkt ja
23 punkte aber da hätte ich echt gedacht
dass mehr leute gucken ja karten kann
das noch irgendwer oder so ein video
stimmt
sowie helfer
profis auch so jemand der wird so auch
der trägt auch zum schlafen die krawatte
sowie fotos und videos
aus dem wetter raus damit die mir wäre
so die hausschuhe an aber so
aussagen der davon weg hat der
staatsanwältin hatte da so drauf ist es
noch einmal zu einem knopf im raum desto
niedriger
die wunderlampe die so richtig leise
anfängt zu leicht an stimmen tageslicht
und so leise melodie die immer lauter
wird
schmeckt sowie mit einer augenmaske
ich glaube nicht
die tiere
oder nach einem meeting ja stimmt
trinkt sein wasser nicht aus einer
flasche am bett sondern jetzt auch klar
ist auch alles so tötete zuerst ins glas
und trägt aber aus dem urteil setzt
darunter unten untersagt norwegen carina
januar ihren
schneid tobi weis ich nicht wieso jemand
der der schnarcht aber dann geht er zum
arzt damit
tasten funktionieren nicht laptop
tastatur reparieren das wie findet man
so ein video wenn die tasten nicht
mit dem handy
ja ich glaube tatsächlich aber dass das
relativ viele autofahrt ich stell dir
mal so auf zwei millionen
28.000
das war eine tischdecke dieser utopie zu
hause
hatte wie auch so will gewisse tage
wurst so fisch gibt haben sie zum essen
dies gibt fisch
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das highlight der woche
trägt sie auch irgendwie über zu viele
sachen auf die so ahlmann es machen aber
er ist halt selber so einer wie windig
die früh wie am flughafen
aber so wie kate mit der bahn zum garten
beim flughafen preise
ja das passt auch aber irgendwie stress
mit der bahn ist auch nicht so oder so
ist also jemand der kommt dann aus dem
unionslager
ja mit dem viele wagen dann wenn jemand
in den firmenwagen beim ausparken
angefahren oder
haben flug
dann mit jetlag und dann noch darum
kümmern irgendwann endlich zu hause und
dann machen die nachbarn party oder so
der arme aber tobi an dem ich das heute
wieder ist allerdings auch wenn meine
lieben freunde wenn euch unsere rost an
tobi gefallen
aber nicht mal ein kleiner blick auf die
glocke tobi werde das wir lieben dich
bruder soll ich sowas nochmal machen mit
habe nie irgendwas mit die youtube
sachen erraten oder vielleicht instagram
bilder leicht erraten oder sohn schreibt
und in die kommentare haben das letzten
drei worte
bis bald
[Musik]
so
aber ist gar kein problem wie geht's dir